all right and we are live welcome to the
iron Lords podcast episode number 65 if
it's another glorious Sunday we are back
at the roundtable on the Lord's Day and
today the realm will rejoice we have the
e3 2018 prediction series the final
chapter and Microsoft is up to bat we
have saved the very best for last
and I'm extremely proud to have all this
Xbox royalty here at the round table so
let's get right into it
so I want to introduce a Lord who is an
absolute legend in these xbox streets as
the game of score to prove it and
there's another one of my top 5 dead or
alive content creators in the game this
Lord always provides extremely high
quality content in a clear concise and
balanced manner yet is never afraid to
ruffle a few feathers with his brutal
honesty introducing the creator and host
of the xbox two podcasts the man with
the million sitting on the achievement
iron throne mr. soft-serve himself
my man Lord Randolph oh how you doing
sir what is going on guys I am super
excited to be back on iron Lords podcast
as this is one of my favorite shows out
there
what about incognito you are the best
host let's appreciate it very humbled
sir very almost recovered from you very
humbled at this point I don't even think
it's the whole the whole introduction I
just think it's that introduced we got
Lord reyne is an absolute pleasure one
of the xbox mob bosses in the building
this is this is a good day and of course
last but by no means least we have one
of our most earlier supporters in the
realm and an absolute icon at the round
table this Lord is by far one of the
most passionate members of the Xbox
community and with the
single tweet and galvanize the entire
base to focus on what's most important
in these gaming streets introducing the
voice of the people and the Lord
everyone is honored to cross paths with
at e3 fellow met fan fellow Cosworth
Fair who puts the beast fight in 4k
Scorpio my man no a to dog are you doing
sir I love it and you're the best in the
business of the intros I have to say
very happy and a pleasure of them ready
to get going on this as you call it the
mob round table we might be we might be
missing somebody might be in the trunk
right now waving we close it absolutely
absolute pleasure has been fun to have
you back on this show always have fun
and of course you know we got the Four
Horsemen of gaming those usual suspects
at the round table
my co-host with the co most my brother
from another mother the difficult game
Conqueror and the half of the young wolf
mommy's Lord addict are you doing sir
what's going on you guys I appreciate
everyone from showing up it should be
sleeping because apparently that's what
I do all the time good I'm feeling that
though and of course we have our most
technical gaming Lord the solo gamer who
lives for the single player selfish
experience and also the sastra Thomas
mr. or flam profile Illuminati and Lord
patreon himself good man I'm excited
family in the building after two weeks
of terrorizing King and King having to
bring smoking King can lay back and know
that he's amongst friends today
can we deal with those those Sony and
Nintendo prediction series
I'm just not on a hyperbole train that's
gonna sit there be like I gotta switched
buy it real quick though on that patreon
supplies today's gonna be the first day
that we all go into our you know our
monthly shoutouts and everything our
prize giveaways for the patreon we're
gonna leave it for the end of the show
so please stick around after outros
we're gonna make sure everybody gets
there just do um I guess their big ups
for coming out and supporting us so
please at the end of the show after
outro stick around I'll do all that good
stuff patron with the announcement thank
you and of course we got the Incredible
Hulk of this aka
excess gamer the Lord of combat sports
who was a man of his convictions demands
nothing less than that premium
experience and is to get money game be
lovely to pause between that like a guy
we doing say we're doing fantastic you
know what it is today is full
appreciation I'll see the set up but I
ain't gonna fall for that trap field um
check this out I just want to give a
shout out and the thanks to everybody
that show it all the support it's so
fantastic to see the overwhelming I
really had a I'll pick my own pick
then t-shirts that I thought was gonna
be like the standout pic is always
standing and it's easy to go with that
that it's black but their white is
moving though and it's really crazy now
I'm gonna give a show of the shirts at
the end and give you the swag and tag
while we add a III so y'all can follow
along Cognito and I adjourn this week
we're gonna drop a swag attack video
showing off the shirts again separately
from the podcast so you guys can follow
and understand how to follow us in
California if you're out there at e3 how
to find us and eat me because it's very
important that you find us for the free
game raffle sack all right there's three
games that will be raffled off and this
is what the raffles look like the
raffles is attached to a card you have
to see the Lord and the Lord will give
you a card on that card it would be a
raffle and on that raffle that's you get
a game maybe you might win also will you
buy a shirt you get a free raffle all
right so good luck guys no doubt all
right so of course we have the shinobi
gaming ninja himself Laura kognito
spreading that realness in the realm of
the ILP now telling you what you want to
hear but what you want to hear so uh
let's get into what the Lords of playing
with this week start with a lord Ren
what have you been playing this week
yeah well you know he keeps killing me
in gamer school I don't know what he's
beating gamer score then you are in
months and I basically played pub G
again for this entire month so if
anybody if I'm still beating you then
you ain't you ain't nothin love is what
you say exactly exact and I like that
but I've been on that ps4 playing
Detroit no no achievements so you know
you can't complain
last month
oh no I can't you you got 3,400 debts
that is you know I played the crew beta
2 beta you really like that like you
can't wait to play aging playing I know
I saw him on my map
I felt I kind of thought maybe I should
go like bump into him but don't please
man if you would've did that you might
have died from a heart attack say that
he was happy with it until he started
flying a plane
yes yeah yeah her planes would like
controlled horribly the planes there
they're my least favorite but I really
like the driving and the boats and stuff
so I enjoyed that
Detroit become human was a was a great
experience on the PlayStation but I am a
fan of that genre you to in the same way
I just thought the interactive movie
cinematic experience simulator yeah look
gorgeous has some really good moral
choices great story great cast
Oh exact thing is amazing in that game I
saw some have been playing this month
it's just not my thing like I played it
for 20 hours and that's about it I I
don't really feel compelled go back and
play it
same thing like would see a thieves I
just mean you did like 20 hours into it
yeah but I don't know I just I I see why
people like it
I'm not necessarily the heute biggest
fan of like managing a community and
doing all that stuff it honestly felt
like a lot of busy work like I just want
to go and like clear the plague hearts
and kind of like do all that stuff
it requires you be like hey there's an
infestation go go get rid of that and
then you go get rid of the infestations
and then two more infestations pop up
but I'm just like I think that game
would have a lot more mass popularity if
they included some sort of mode that
just mate like let you do the action II
stuff like like you said to play hearts
and the shooting and like killing things
and then just give you the option if you
want to do all the you know all the like
base building stuff because I can see
how they can get tedious if you do if
that's not your thing then so that's
pretty much what's been going on with
Lord reyne lore Tim dogwood you've been
rocking this week man what you be
playing that's pretty funny because I
didn't play in state of decay and it is
it is a game that I you know I wind
blows through games like a guy that you
call in the next day the kind of guy
that gets triple whatever the average
person gets a game of course the good
truck really doesn't know how to blow
through a game and really take what's
all about it and take it in and decipher
and stuff and I do agree with him in the
fact that the game he stresses me out I
like the game but it stresses me out
like I don't like feeling that like when
I and I go to my inventory and I looked
at my my thing and I see all red my
people are dying its crisis men the game
never gives you that sense of like com4
into your freaking into your the world
you know that that that that that that
that part of it is the end of the world
and it really feels like the end of the
world but Isis like your mental status
on what the end of the world is what is
like the most into the world apocalypse
that's ever been made sunset overdrive
no but I do feel that you know I do feel
like it's a it's a good game but it
misses it would benefit from having
things I really said the arcade mode
because there is never a downtown
there's never where you could just sit
back and feel like how well I feel good
about this and this is gone
the game is hectic but some people love
that type of stuff and and I think that
it's overall to the game it's a very
difficult thing for me at least you know
I mean to handle all that stuff because
absolutely you're like I'm always you
know I like like I played with you know
addict we played and I have fun like
that I like playing on somebody else's
server and gathering stuff yeah actually
I've been playing them leaving arms at
the end I've been playing gears too and
yeah and I have to say you know I'm
playing used to play a game like this
and you saw how Microsoft at the time
got it like this is X plus you know
we're gonna go into that but that's
what's that starts players want they
want those tech teams and knocking
leymah theme is just epic just yeah even
though you're playing it enhanced and
it's a old game it's tastic it still
looks fantastic but just the the scope
and the size of it and just the way
you're fighting the you know the locusts
and you're going into her you know your
brain
and you have to get to the middle of the
place of the Empire and just the way
they set it up and presentation is
fantastic
I have to say I it made me kind of even
you know like similar probably all
talking about this believing question
where Microsoft is now I mean they need
something like hey I hear what you go
and I ever get into it what's up Tim
kind of took one of my prediction he
started he started to talk about it to
be honest with you just a little bit of
everything I've been playing a lot of
things might you know really let break
that with Butchie I doubt the cloud some
of that he said Oh sounds like a project
so did you big force to do sounds like
money's being exchanged to play this but
I was watching
well first off it kind of like I started
playing before they announced games with
gold and then when a lot of people don't
know this but that games let's go for
smite that's not even on the store like
I looked on I was like well what is that
cuz I was gonna buy some heroes and I
was like I'm not gonna buy heroes that
they're gonna give the heroes to me at
the middle of the month and I looked on
the store and that's not on the store
that's nowhere to be found in the store
I've no clue what that is okay so that's
pretty much it has been all all smite
all day every day it's for this no not
every day I've been playing some Dark
Souls 2 actually okay cool oh you like
digging into Crais this week I like that
addict the despite there was a lot of
you know people took we're taking shots
at Xbox the games for gold for being at
free do you feel like that was being
- it was it was a value I liked up to
code of a big spike right at the end of
the day it might not be what people
wanted to be but smites a huge game and
a lot of people play it and it's a free
to play game so all you have to
literally do is downloading you if it's
a $99 on there that's got to be all the
heroes so you know regardless how people
I'm not even a big smile fan I yeah said
it was $99 in / - free app nope it's not
on the store I have no clue what it is
we don't really it's not for us but I'm
sure it's gonna be a lot of people like
that [ __ ] but you know here's the
question did you suite about how it was
trash ran spy named trash but it's trash
for being including games of gold
it couldn't definitely been way better
but let's be a hundred it could have
been way worse people like at least you
can literally just play that and
probably have people to play with have
plenty of concerts to do they could've
gave us some [ __ ] that they don't know
in game past oh that is the first part
but they're gonna do that
right when you said it could be worse I
mean they did give us brave kid from
playing I played bring it back on the
360 but I'm just saying no I'm not
validating that that was trash I just
say there's this there's like eight
how'd you break just get all the game
you're gonna play brave you better get
all the achievements you play go over
though
what are you playing it for but they
look like people pay for Xbox Live Gold
beyond the majority probably the vast
majority played to get the multiplayer
access maybe the party chat stuff but
the quality of the free games
technically really hasn't been up to
snuff lately and reason behind
definitely speaking of with loss off
what have you been playing not that much
I wanna stay dedicated little bit
yesterday I want to see how the new
patch was I didn't have too much I
couldn't honestly I just wanted to see
if I wasn't you know clipping through
the world anymore because to me that was
that was the one thing that was
happening I don't know to made stuff
worse on PC I mean it was fine for me I
didn't notice I didn't know
they've been crazy different I was they
were times when I get stuck in a car in
like a railing on the road or whatever
and I would not come out and then you
know like that rewind function doesn't
work when you're in a car it's only when
you're on foot so you'd be screwed I
just have to leave the car behind and
whatever so now I was able to like go in
reverse and it came out so I'm assuming
they fixed some stuff in that in that
regard
um gotcha and then beyond that um I
downloaded Detroit but I haven't been
able to play so I'm excited to get that
started Oh go go to that patreon my
friend
I forgot to mention guys there's a
couple new tears have been added to
patreon to express individual you know
[Music]
he plays in a pub pub jito the King
plays like it it's it's like different
games it's gotta be they gotta play
together when we play in different games
to much same game I got to see this
stream okay work there's no problem with
that no problem
I'm doing the real squads real serious
me yeah see that's what it is is when
you jump on the play Pub G and this is
the problem that I'm having with pub G
this is the only problem that I'm having
the squad's I have really probably a
strong 15 friends that I can play with
and if we can get squads 25 against 25
that'd be great then I can actually play
with my whole whole roster dude but I'm
rotating with people putting people in
groups of 4 here groups of four there
let me slide over the destiny here let
me come back and do this here so really
my game of school would never move with
these catching up to a million
gamerscore ok that if you're a party
with the four guys they're so serious
like ran just like he's like that like
you don't want anyone in the party chat
talking him messing with your console we
have to listen to the environment that
game is so immersive that we listen to
the environment we listen to the
squirrel we're gonna call out numbers we
gotta check stuff person behind the
rocket 240 did you just understand that
understood when I said you don't
understand why don't you let me finish
my statement
oh you acted like it's like a rain and
Destin you gotta call out numbers not
enemies it's two entirely different
things
coordinates you're calling out let me
let me let me articulate it then human
speed opposed to pub G speak okay
because we allow yellow coordinates we
got no time for that we have enough time
to say yell out the numbers that's
it's been primarily pub deviously you
know what it is just been on like I said
now babe it's so busy man obviously we
know it prepping for next week and
everything but I did a little obvious
little destiny lo state of decay I
touched the state decay after the 20 gig
patch like very minutely but I did see
some differences that some improvement
did a little coop scenes from different
shots now though he did some PC cross
play it was found on my side so it was
good and then um actually just like when
I started Detroit became human I did the
the first chapter game is fantastic
again you have to be into that kind of
walking simulator kind of thing and I
love it crash fantastic so I've been
feeling it so that's been me so I'm
obviously gonna get into what we are
here for and that's the prediction
series it's the excitement is building
up in the State of the Union let's start
with the the actual you know the state
of xbox you know ups as far as like the
this in general how we feeling about the
brand you know the highs and lows you
want to talk about and just is there
pressure for Microsoft coming in
I think Microsoft has the most approve
out of any of the companies going into
e3 I think a lot of people are craving a
road map they want to know the games
coming not only for this year but for
next year and beyond whereas their
competition has provided like the road
map since 2016 basically so people
people want to people want to know like
is there a fable is there a perfect dark
when's the next Halo one's the next
gears and the call the cry of the Xbox
fan has been for years now and Tim Tim
has kind of led the charge on this
that's been maybe not this year but
previous years wait for III only three
three and Tim I think you said this was
last year you'd say that right so so we
needed to say that you know Lauren like
we feel that the the pressure is there
because obviously we need to have an
idea of the future that that's kind of
like you would want that roadmap so to
speak right so and almost like a
breaking of protocol so to speak of what
normally happens underneath it kind of
easy to get that yeah this is different
like last year known quantities were
showing off see at the eve state of
decay crackdown even in previous years
they would you would know you know what
to expect because they revealed stuff so
early right but this is the first e3 in
a long time words literally okay it's
just crackdown and nothing else
Oh anything else third parties will be
plentiful they'll be great as they
always are but unfortunately third party
games can be played anywhere well they
can be played best on xbox right now
which is
good for Microsoft but they're third
parties are basically you know they're
there they're basically just [ __ ] man
anybody had come in it's true people
tuned in to watch these conferences to
see the exclusive experiences that they
can have on their platform of choice
that they prefer people tune into Sony
is to check out you know what does last
us - gonna be like or death stranding a
ghost Ashima they don't really care that
Call of Duty's they're a read dad maybe
they're or whatever that's not what the
talk is about it's about those exclusive
games people want to tune into
Microsoft's yeah they'll be Metro
they'll be cyberpunk and stuff like that
and that'll get some talk but the
conversation afterwards will be what is
Microsoft doing exclusive wise is there
is what's ears up to what's halo up to
is their new IP and if Microsoft doesn't
deliver on that front people are going
to people are going to be upset by
frankly yeah absolutely
they don't bring them darts what is my
turn I'm gonna give you exactly you know
how I feel for me personally it's not a
make-or-break for me narrative out here
Lori because I have every system right
I'm gonna play something on PlayStation
that they provide I'll play it there
right I'm gonna play something on switch
I'll play it there help I have a brand
new PC you know it's got a it's got a
you know a 1080 in it I didn't play any
game pretty much in 4k on my PC if I
wanted to I don't so I'm kind of looking
at Xbox I'm like okay well what do you
what are you bringing like sure we know
all about the problems they had in the
past Terry Myerson squeezed in the
budget taking over Xbox being removed
from underneath windows to its own
separate division with decisions in the
benefit for Xbox we know about all these
things and yes I know that games take a
long time to build games like God of War
five years and I'm not expecting a
miracle within a year turnaround so
I'm going into this III with about low
expectation expectation because the
games that I think people want and the
people and that they are making just
aren't ready to show you because they're
still two to three years away you're
making fantastic I sort of cut you on
one things I do just a counterpoint to
what your what you're saying I think
everything you're saying is accurate the
counterpoint to what I'm hearing for
what you're saying is that people say
hey you know I invested in this brand
and they have disappointed me this
entire generation like we need to
quote-unquote be on them to be better
and it's unacceptable to say hey wait
till next year wait till next year what
do you say to that contingent who pretty
much on their last straw and they're
frustrated with Microsoft right that if
frustrated with Xbox what do you say to
that I mean if you're frustrated with
Microsoft that is your personal right as
a consumer and I mean I can't tell you
not to to move away or just to stay I
mean that's not like that's not
Microsoft to prove they're in it to win
it that they have things that people
want if you're like are we talking about
someone who legitly is moving or one of
those one of those fake people I've seen
this I mean I mean I'm not gonna say any
names whatever and I've got a lot of a
lot of friends that they're like look
man this is it if I don't see anything
from and they passionately love
Microsoft when they say hey if they
don't see anything from them this year
that's it they're not buying any more
Microsoft products you know for the
next-gen I'll say you want to you want
to make your voice heard know what
speaks the loudest where your mouth is
provide you what you want put your money
where your mouth you know I would I
would say move your purchases to
PlayStation Microsoft will see the drop
in revenue they will see that stuff
that's the only thing you can do I mean
you sure you can get up on Twitter and
you can cry and complain videos
look that's also the thing is like
Microsoft has heard all that right they
know that people are not in like the
best of moods or like not really feeling
it right now but like it's it's a video
game industry like you know everything
went behind it the whole Terry Meyers
and stuff like the no budgets at Xbox
heads now they do they're already in for
next-gen problem is unfortunately the
fruits of those labors aren't gonna be
seen for a long time so we can get up
here and complain and [ __ ] about it
it's it's just I don't know what else
they even say because they've heard it
they're working on it they can't show it
so in the meantime if you're really
about that life then buy the multiplayer
someplace I mean if you're really at
that point we're disappointed in it and
you're upset that there are two other
consoles to play on no because if you're
if you if you're at that point and then
you continue to give Microsoft money
what are you telling Microsoft at that
point you're telling Microsoft that
you're perfectly happy happy because in
the at the end but at the end of the day
this last thing I'll say in this actions
speak louder than words salute that may
right day long rant is killing it right
now let's get a little team dog in the
building with the state of Microsoft
heading in to e3 what are your what
you're feeling you feel the pressure do
you feel don't suppose want to talk
about our long-term know what you feel
actually would like the highs and the
lows of the year so far so the floors
yours um you know I'll just go into what
ran said I think that Rand really kind
of laid it out there you know I think -
offenses around would be we know but the
fact is is that Twitter is my not
minority and YouTube is minority the
fact is is we're making money and they
are and they're making profit now when
we talk about Xbox the state Xbox for me
personally I think
now what you're seeing is a reciprocal
effect of not keen producing for two
years boom and that black hole that they
have is now rearing its ugly head and
going into this III I have set it to
make or break Google you feel so I I've
seen your time Lantern you have you been
very adamant but you know if I'm gonna
be honest I don't think that they're
gonna they're gonna quiet down the
people that are upset right no they're
not to you know this as well as I do you
know I think that that you have to go
into that legitimately understanding
they're not gonna hit a home they're not
gonna hit the grand slam that we all
want oh I wish I could say to you say
guys
wait just wait there and you know I wish
I could get behind that that train and
believe me that's what I really really
want a huge fan of them I really want to
be in that position but realistically I
look at how the janitors went and some
of the things that have been said and
some of the promises that have not
really been kept that I do think that
they are in my kind of a rebuilding
stage and you are talking about the
first year from rebuilding so they just
sign there they're their stars but
though they're stars they can't show
them right now because they're in single
a ball they're nowhere near is ready
while you have games like people mobile
and perfect dark that I would say I'm
over eighty percent sure that their
balls and development as we speak
you're not going to see them halo six
you're not going to see because that's
kind of been done they kind of pushed
that back I think that our years five is
actually moved okay Wow
we might see years five we won't even
get a Master Chief with the poncho and a
desert we won't even we don't get the
child I don't think that you will and I
hope you were more
I don't think I get what you might get
is is I do think that they're gonna talk
with this this new guy in the Santa
Monica studio and then Daryl Gaudi yeah
I figured arigato and and and booty are
both gonna kind of give you that roadmap
and say that you know I'm hoping this is
what I'm hoping that they say that they
invested this amount of money and they
have this amount of IP scouring kind of
like what they did in 2013 which was
actually a very good show but as you
know was you know flipped on but if they
could duplicate like that type of show
but that that would be a huge win in my
eyes because then they're at least
giving the wrong map but I'm not
expecting a big III I'm expecting in my
my expectations are average okay I do
think that we're gonna get these are
things that I'm gonna protect I think we
have something on the surface side means
might piss people off but I do think
that they have some type of weather that
it's an Xbox cloud there's something
that is gonna you know I have a lot of
value to it and it's gonna be another
you know type of thing that they stick
to you as a gamer of Xbox so I do think
that is good but obviously it's not what
the meat and potatoes what we want right
so take you'll see that I do think that
you will see Gallagher and booty give a
semi roadmap and I do think they will
talk about the new studio and what
they're building I do think that Phil
will actually talk about some of this so
I do think that in that case we will get
some of the assurances that we kind of
want but I don't think that we'll be
able to see them and that's gonna be
where the show kind of doesn't hit its
home run because you're not gonna see
fable you're not gonna close on perfect
dark you know I mean rands who has
excellent sources and you know if you
want to check out his III prediction
video I think that money was pretty much
on target got a realistic things he said
you know Ram last year had told me to
close in on a triple chip on the third
party way before this and he told me
about anthem and you know I knew about
it I mean I keep my sources you know I
keep it quiet so
[Music]
and I've given him but the thing is that
you know he might have heard the same
thing again which I think that you
closed you on the triple a
multi-platinum
not a great statement I hope that's not
true I'm hoping that they close on gears
five so I'm going to say anything close
on years five with footage okay and
that's pretty much where it's gonna be I
think that you're gonna have a oh you
said the highs and lows are highs have
been xbox one X is clearly a tremendous
enough credit for that
Bri TX is amazing hi once the low the
lows are just be continued you know you
see the competition and and it's hard to
say hello is coming from the competition
but the competition like when I played
years to like I said and I said this is
what I want
you got the competition right now
absolutely just chilling it and it puts
them in a precarious position you know
what I mean so even though that they've
gotten a lot of games that they Sony
have had exclusive like you know
supposedly near and they got a hell
played and they did a good job on that
front it really doesn't matter because
you know those games have already been
out they've been out a year and years
it's kinda like a nice guy thing yeah
exactly I think they've done a decent
job kind of recovering on the game
aspect so I do think that the because of
what the competition is doing it just
kind of like it kind of kills this
situation it kind of kills their talking
points so the lows have been just you
know I just think that they're in a
situation where you know they're getting
killed on social media it's like if I
just said to me cuz I'll turn what do
you think this is why I said I think I
think Twitter and YouTube is gonna be
bad for a long time for Xbox I think
it's going to be
you know just the best Rest but I do
think in the overall aspect Xbox is
doing good it's just that you know from
the social media they're gonna get
killed and I don't expect any of that to
turn around unfortunately
I got they got they got they got a
really work hard now and you know build
back faith I don't think they're gonna
lose mass fans like I original I think
that they've already start to lost when
you see guys like keV and you see jazz
not the other jazz and you see red
dragons kind of like that you see a lot
of the hardcore guys and then you see
also the hardcore acts of the Xbox guys
that once expose guys now you can say it
oh I'm getting a PC FF you know they're
they're getting they're getting you know
the front to that but I do think that
it's just a rebuilding phase and and I
do think hopefully if they get this
right that we can get some of these
games that you know other competitions
have had these you know the ones that
they've been dying for the triple-eight
bangers that are you know deep in scope
and pushing real power of powerful
narrative mm-hm fair enough fair enough
let's get the Lords in on this Oh Lord
addict what's your feeling on the state
of Microsoft and Xbox coming in the e3
um do we really have enough time yeah
just pretty good just breeze through
just a feeling just a feeling I do think
that they got a narrative that you know
the minority might not speak for a lot
but the minority on Twitter and
YouTube's was given the perspective and
right now they are losing the
perspective on every corner because who
do you think's on Twitter and stuff
people that sell their product they keep
seeing stuff like that I mean it's no
secret that the retailers they they they
will favorite them the majority you know
game stock against top and although I'm
sure you know low key behind closed
doors they're being asked to push more
PlayStation products than xbox part
because they get more PlayStation barata
it's just at the end of the day
if you can't change that perspective
that narrative you can't really do a
whole lot and you know I understand they
don't want to show stuff because sure
the Jersey said they're gonna announce a
shopping cart for the windows I
understand where they're coming from I
understand that they don't want to show
games they'd have another sale bound
direction and to be honest with you I
don't see it happening but at the end of
the day can they go another two years
boom can they go another year or two not
announcing anything before they before I
mean you you have people that's been on
YouTube and I know it's like I said it's
the minority but when they're getting
thousands of thousands of views twenty
to forty thousand views like that's
that's the narrative going down the
[ __ ] true in sets of perspective
yeah I kinda I'm kind of nothing to
operate cuz I've kind of had this
argument with with some of the Xbox
people and I don't think that they get
that I do think you can underestimate
the YouTube community definitely does
arrested me what they see on on on
Twitter some of the stuffs like the red
flags that you see like when year's
awards kind of Wars coming out you got
like guys like you know some of the
mixture guys just going not just like
[Music]
push that out you here's the big thing
that might that Sony's killing Microsoft
right now from if they got stuff to
market that looks appealing where do you
think their market right now you know
people keep saying you know the people
on Twitter aren't the hardcore yeah but
uh the people the hardcore you know what
they're doing at YouTube they're wanting
Fortnight gameplay when they go into
these streams and these that what do you
think ads are popping up god of war you
don't see any other kind of ads popping
up you might see you see these that pop
up and people like oh that looks cool
but then the next ad that pops up Scott
always like now I'm getting a ps4 like
that is what they're losing it's like I
said from the start like once you almost
nine times out of ten if you lose coming
out the gate you lose the whole
generation and we all know that they
stumbled out the gate it had one of the
worst starts up here because you know
sir I think at the beginning of the
generation that's when the hardcore is
the most vital to get that hardcore
audience because a lot of the times
who's gonna be buying consoles day one
hardcore you know there's gonna be
casuals in there obviously you got
people like King David got more money
than they know what to do with so
they're gonna go buy that dumb [ __ ] it's
who who do you think convinces people to
buy what if you have a thousand core
Xbox one ones and you have 15,000 ps4s
and they and you're gonna have the
15,000 people tell a friends before you
know that 15s forty thousand right you
have the one thousand Xbox ones and that
one thousands four thousand effect
there's definitely there's no there's no
doubt about that and I do think that's
where they lost it was like you know it
working obviously that is the moment
they came out and they lost from that
big gap the thing is what King mentions
is true but at the same time a lot of
that goes back to not recognizing the
mistakes you made in the past and how
they've affected where you are right now
like it's too right to hear them going
into e3 and not recommend and they're
gonna be safe with their announcements
and not recognizing the magnitude and
the power of what a you know
quote-unquote winning III means um then
it kind of feels like they're not having
paid attention to what put them in the
race to begin with and that's a scary
thing because you gotta listen to what I
think they're at a point where they have
to they have to be confident enough in
what they're bringing down the pipeline
to say or
at least one thing that's three years
out two years out we're gonna announce
it cuz I know it's not breaking protocol
at the end of the day I think their
best-case scenario you know we've talked
to R and we know this ain't gonna happen
is they need to take the most idyllic
franchise that they have in development
that they know for a fact is coming out
and they show that [ __ ] this year
because let's be honest like I
understand their grin up to next gen
they ain't gonna have next gen they're
just not cuz when you go into next gen
off like nothing what do you what do you
think well here after the ps3 ps4 they
came off of the ps3 with Last of Us yeah
I mean I just want to say something is
really making great points you know you
talk about it and I think this is this
ties in to what what Alex said you talk
about and the way that they started off
this chant everyone said don't don't
announce the RM well oh do I
or do what Sony did everyone said that
up to that day they had any kind of Dave
listen to that hardcore they just would
have said guess what you can get games
done that and they would have been a
huge hit then everyone will look to 2030
we're not a situation it's kind of the
same thing we're all here saying do it's
Arlington look at Saudi nobody cares
everyone said oh that's great it was a
softball that this guy just couldn't hit
over the gate hey the salt boy was lob
to him he's getting hit it over the gate
actually he bunted it the first base and
got called out it was horrible
I stepped in I watched them and I
watched Sony push back this show for an
hour but this go back to the point is
Microsoft it's so Microsoft versus
but what about listen what about two
like we just said well you all just said
we wanted and let's say the show is
still not finalized right yeah break
Fosse goods to say you know what this
game is not getting cancelled it's gonna
come out whether it works and show it
and they're not gonna do that I think it
was 14 I can't remember the the one that
that Tomb Raider was announced which one
was that
greater rise to die I thought that was a
great pacing show they showed everything
that's coming out as this year and next
year and then they had like a segment
after all that that showed stuff that's
in the future yeah and like that's the
kind of pacing that you need people
don't want know people want to see we're
not this is speculation King I can't say
guy though next week I'm not a time King
I think the biggest key thing that they
have right now it don't still get
clowned on people just want to know they
have games coming it doesn't even matter
for here now they just want to know
their stuff in the in the pipework sure
those Soviet clown that there's not
games coming out next year this year but
they will they will some people will be
like okay they got games coming look
look what Sony does and I'm not trying
to say copy everything Sony does but
it's working to a point absolutely we
know that strategies coming we know
ghosts and Kashima is coming out I
didn't put you that name but at the end
of the day we just want to know
something's coming
we don't want to hear rumors we wouldn't
especially at e3 as fact
that was a shadow just that was a shout
out because I'm
and I definitely understand your
frustration
so that was grinding my gears and that
was a shout-out to you sir just stop you
Minds infringement the payment is in the
PayPal we gotta move on we got a couple
things get into yeah do also we have a
120 viewing let's get them lights up
let's push this little moon you know you
got ran in here you got in here the Lord
all right let's do to make you take
notice all right no no now what I've
noticed and then what I hear and I had a
frustration you know why because I hit
it genesis of your frustration the
Genesis is your frustration is this tool
served up a softball and he couldn't hit
it and I get it I get he walked into the
show he was able to do this than a dirt
but no they was telling him don't do
that DRM don't do that DRM and what did
he do do the DRM oh my god and then what
Sony did right after him
slow that show up sure this fax people
don't talk about they show us the
shortest and when you got your
PlayStation at home it took you damn
near 24 hours to remove DRM address real
quick in the comic know that said that
uh MLM I said what did the marketing
have to do can we all agree here the
Sony's market he's been on point this
whole generation or how the hell you
gonna frickin hype state of decay really
on a triple-a level or even see a
thieves it's not are not games those
games were designed for a situation of
the PayPass a game past you know okay
that's right nobody in slip it was
designed for that model alright they
have games that's coming in and I'm
pretty sure just like Tim dog and I
chopped it up last year right and we
watch the show on he asked me you know
honestly you know how I felt about the
show and I thought
adequate I didn't think the show blue
anybody away I had reservations with
ending on somebody else's IP which I
brought up and you know listen a lot of
these situations and these moves are
being made under constraints all right
it takes a superior individual to move
in a hostile climate and the hostile
climate is Twitter YouTube Facebook
anything that can any multimedia social
media that is pushing us down because
trust me is very easier to run with the
crowd not too many people are given me
today Xboxes they have a sitting there
maybe it's collecting dust or if they're
not you know they they want to play a
God of War yeah don't forget without
this failure from Microsoft those card
Awards those games probably wouldn't
have come to pass because they were on
their last ill in the villa now a lot
I'm still waiting develop a were all
right so they still in development but
if they falter in the beginning of this
generation those those does those games
come out in a manner that they do they
were able to sit back because remember
right so if had all these games in the
beginning of the generation where people
screaming I was a game for Sony right
fax but here in the Sony presence and
say I have no clue why people would find
PS floors yes because it was no games
there but the games are here now so
everybody's gonna hold on to this
rhetoric dead oh the games have always
been in no the games have not always
been there this drought is on us now the
drought is on us and it won't change
let's be honest yeah our a lot of it was
power I remember how we ran three beat
from ATP and 900p
huge I mean huge and now it around for
you I'm gonna make that assure you know
Phil listen Phil let and feel them told
you I'm gonna fix this
you know the power narrative is over now
they talk of PlayStation 5 narrative is
done you know right little you gotta
watch exactly so when they showed you
that 4k screen if you was that easy that
4k sweetie look beautiful look for you
it was the best screen I've seen cuz we
went to the PC show it now listen my
state of Xbox in going in I expect this
and I really truly believe by watching
his moves
alright and I know you're gonna call me
a Phil stand I'll take that a loss
because when it's right it's right when
it's wrong it's wrong he has a lot of
stuff that he's introduced to you that
game past it works great for the family
right side up your kid is fantastic and
you paying cheaply every month to keep
your kids ecstatic keep itself ecstatic
and get Xbox exclusives uh what just
didn't like was that a Halo game at
David you're gonna don't touch but right
now he has changed the power narrative
so they can't do that what you do
strategically to your enemy has removed
their ammo and he's been removing the
ammo little by little pass digital
foundry announce your system and show
the superiority of your system because
digital foundry was a major component in
your demise so you put them on your back
as your ally and it's working alright so
these games I believe this year will be
shown and like addicts said I honestly
believe that show that he thought was
the best had the best pacing I honestly
believe that they will use that type of
narrative to show a role Maps not too
far ahead but some games that you can
know that's going to be tangible that
they have a good eye on because when you
pull back scalebound and we also
scalebound and look Genki don't lie
friday nobody doesn't rain can attest to
this but knio knio game had a five page
thread on
on its showing on on on neogaf about
what it showed it at Gamescom whatever
weird how how much was the cancellation
thread what was that
hundreds hundreds so there was nothing
was not a lot of high me and green have
always talked about that game
nobody was had four people would say to
look horrible and I Got News for You
gonna do is talk about the Platinum
stuff I know a lot of things that went
on there that'll never be said in the
poll and um that game was not even close
to being ready in 2016 it would have
been another two years but it's like I
told kids small this is you're gonna
have repercussions when you ever cancel
whether right or wrong and that and and
you could say you know it wasn't
Microsoft fault but it wasn't in the
fact that maybe if they had overseen
this to be the situation better earlier
that they could have fixed it but they
didn't but that whole situation with
that game was if it came out it would
not be a beginning and would not have in
my opinion we're not salad and and
people would not have made the big deal
I mean I never seen so many people never
talked about it
understand I think I think just came
down to the fact that it was a unique
looking title and it was something that
usually Xbox those type of times we
don't want you on xbox I think right so
I do commercially but it's one of those
things and I don't know if Lauren agree
with this like I think one of the
appeals of sone is that they have that
diversity in their lineup right whereas
let's be honest you know mark so falls
into that trap of the gears halo Forza
and when you see something that they're
promoting that's unique from that space
there's a contingent that is hiked for
it you know I mean I'm not saying the
whole base was who knows what it was
absolutely but um yeah it's gonna move
on cuz we've been on this this one for a
long I was completely done with that
whole thing wrong but my stay is a whole
different kind of state and it's hopeful
you know going into this III I'm going
in hopeful and confident in a sense that
the same way that these guys woke up
smelling their investments
I believe the numbers
back certain ways on us going into this
e3 I truly honestly believe those games
will be there
now fair enough you got snow heavy damn
point ahead so very much they're just
like my eyes you know obviously X the
lows are obviously you know that you
know obviously did that lack of the
first party I peak the quality the first
and I've see the delayed of the
crackdown which we talked about know a
lot of people talk about too and there
is some pressure so we will get into the
next topic and get this thing moving so
I want to talk about the impact of the
you know rises of services game pass
hanging III obviously we know about the
arcade halo exclusive Dave and Buster's
you know opening you know about the
Miami Street PC Windows 10 so it's just
a slap in the face we get to talking
rant again uh what do you feel about
this you know I mean as far as like just
game pass in general in this direction
is it is it hurtful is it helping what
do you feel personally I don't think
it's hurting anything I think I think
it's it's a boon I think it's wonderful
for Microsoft I mean the the people that
will say game pass exists so Microsoft
can put in broken games or have oh I get
that
and but the thing is like CEO thieves
instead of the cave were development for
game pass was even an idea well you know
those so like those games being the way
they are isn't on game pass it's on rare
and it's on undead labs you know maybe
not getting the support they needed but
from all my talk with people game pass
is the future of literally Xbox they
believe in that that much and they they
believe that with a strong subscriber
base it allows them to invest in games
they couldn't before so that's the way I
look at it okay if you have a situation
where look we've all been disappointed
me especially I know Tim's really
disappointed and I could probably and
you and King and sovereign and attic
probably Wells like this generation has
been
a lost one for Microsoft when it comes I
ski all their games have been won and
done people complain that Sony's games
were one and done but you're truly one
and done because they don't need sequels
you know you know you have a game like
rise which a pretty decent launch title
but arrives too with could have been
could have been something like a step up
like Uncharted uncharted 2 or a Mass
Effect the Mass Effect 2 could have been
great never we won't get to see it
quantum break - you know what other game
am I thinking up here in the pregame
passer because you split them up freedom
post right in the pre game pass era each
individual game was judged on its own
performance quantum break had this
budget did it make a profit yes make a
sequel no don't make a sequel right
since it overdrive did same thing right
and they all didn't do well like they
all just didn't sell but in this era of
game pass each individual title doesn't
necessarily have to perform at a high
standard to get maybe a sequel because
it's all about adding content to the
service to keep people subscribe so you
can have a successful game but then you
also need other games that maybe aren't
as successful it's truly the Netflix
model Netflix has been criticized that
they keep series going on too long and
that they should cancel stuff but they
don't necessarily have to because they
need the content that need people's eyes
on the show's to keep on subscribing
throughout the length of time so I even
posted this to jazz in the podcast
yesterday
imagine if game pass was around when
scalebound was about to cancel does
fable legends get shut down and on a
break were around or do we have a
quantum break to development as sunset
overdrive pilot point valid points I
want to I want to double down on this
cuz you really opened my mind of some
things alright my question though it's
the opposite of fair like what do people
say based on we got we can only have a
short sample size with game pass in
existence right and we have sea of
thieves we have stated decay
and you know the argument you made would
see of these just gorgeous fantastic
looking game with lack of content we
have state state of decay with this deep
simulation great systems but not
necessarily the most polished so what do
you say to those who say you know I'm
concerned about gangs being in game
packs because Microsoft kinda has to
meet this monthly quality of games to be
added to the service so like is the
quality control now going to go down as
a result I understand what your point is
as far as saying saving games like in
the past ech maybe if game has existed
those things may not have been canceled
or you know maybe sequels could have
been birthed but what about like from
the quality control aspect do you have
any reservations or concerns in that
sense what not necessarily because I you
know we know the situation that
surrounded CEO thieves and state of the
k2 if if this is still an issue a year
from now two years from now then clearly
Microsoft is using game pass to launch
unfinished games but I think I think I
think I don't think game pass is a
causation okay those games being
unfinished and not having content
because like I expect for horizon for to
be absolutely phenomenal and that games
gonna be in game I expect gears v to be
great and that's gonna be in game past
and halo 6 and stuff and and other games
so I think it's just it's a you dynasty
I think that it's not that Microsoft is
pushing games out because of that I kind
of think that like with these particular
games I don't think these games they
were supported by Microsoft I don't
think they were really like supported to
that extreme and I do think that when it
comes to except for CDs but I did hear
that like see these them supporting see
things the way they did that was
actually new like like that came
randomly after like one of the Vedas
they saw like the anticipation and the
engagement so they put a little bit more
marketing behind it but I feel like
games that are dead that are designed
and knowing around a premium service
like game paths that will give more when
games are development or around game
pass you'll see better quality games
coming a lot more frequently because
they know it's it's like it's like you
know rant said a lot of these games
weren't even designed with game pass in
mind oh it's some of these games like
you know that these new games in
development they're they're designed
with game possess in mind they're like
this is what we need this out because we
need this by game fast I do feel like
CTS and say these game was pushed out
because the game pass but I don't
Microsoft doing a quality control I just
think it's Microsoft pushing those two
gangs be someone who's helping I think
it was the luck of the draw in terms of
those two games like those are the first
two games they were ready to go in terms
of microphones like you know first first
and second party stuff and and you know
there see if thieves is something new
right so you knew and in this online
persistent world you knew that
regardless of how many beta tests they
had something was not gonna be
completely it wasn't 100% ready to go
you know that's that state of decay as
much as we wanted it to be a true
triple-a game it was just building upon
the things that it's doing it is
difficult to sort of to iron out to the
point where you're never gonna have
issues with it the type of world are
trying to create the systems that are on
top of systems it's difficult so I mean
it's not excusing the the game breaking
bugs and stuff like that but it's just
those are the two games I think Rand is
is correct in saying that like when halo
comes when gear these are gonna be more
polished experiences I definitely think
that now one thing that I don't agree
with it and is that narrative that these
other games were not gonna get sequels
because if not for game passed because
we all know damn well Microsoft has the
money to do it if they wanted to do it
so they create a narrative that's
telling you like no we can't it doesn't
it's not viable we it can't be done as
opposed to no we're not doing it because
it's not gonna make us as much money
right curiosity okay week we kind of
know what happened what to see thieves
in the quantum break they didn't sell
really well and for the most part I
think very well no I'm not talking about
these I'm sorry sunset overdrive like
for the most part like you know they
didn't sell the greatest I do think
sunset overdrive was better you know was
better had a better reception then then
quantum break but at the end of the day
for one break my question is do you guys
think that if there was no issues of
rice do you think we would got of rice
too because I kind of feel like that was
more bad things like political Dan did
money-wise I want you to jump in Tim
well they tried to get rice and they
were denied it they wanted they came to
Crytek Crytek and they said we'll buy
the IP and they said no well they did
want to do that it's not necesarily I
don't think they're willing to do
sequels it's just that the games that
they're willing to do sequels off they
can't they don't only I mean yeah well I
know they everyone there when they own
some stuff but I think on the gamepad
front you know I think lot of people
miss this this and I've seen that
narrative crop up about there you know
this is a nefarious plan by Microsoft
quality control but the fact is that
that was true and that was Microsoft's
real playing then why would they have
delayed crackdown because ready to go
and that was one deepest was available
so and we might give it at the blade to
2019 on crackdown because they're
raiding supposedly multiplayer and
they're renting a ton of stuff so I
think that's a bit silly I think though
game past
honestly has changed the game in the way
games are perceived you know when you
have a game that's gonna get a million
players in the day that in itself is a
huge it's a huge thing even if a lot of
them don't buy and they are playing it's
just the ancients gonna produce more
sales and the it's also gonna get more
you know visibility at this point
they're more war and it's like I said
this isn't a Microsoft is trying to push
games out to have games on the service
this just Microsoft pushed house
unsettle us I mean see thieves and stay
to decay like it's like you know ranches
like people aren't gonna have this this
issue when the actual games that that
you know our disabled a both of those
games of you remember I mean they
delayed both of those games because of
the sheer listen in 2017 we all that
that is the black hole of X access to
game now but that that was two games
that they were supposedly leaning on and
crackdown and they delayed every single
one of them so I just think it - often a
rough patch but I do think a pass is a
great thing I think that it's it's
probably a better thing for a for our
Xbox that it is for the Zoomers although
it's grateful for consumers - I just
feel that you know when Forza horizon
for and Kelo 6 + years 5 comes out
though that's when you'll really start
to see the effect of game passing you
could literally say I heard some talk
that they could have 5 million people
playing halo 6 they won that's all day
one that is some serious serious gotta
give that as far as engagement and stuff
like that yeah one thing I just want to
get rent quick question I'll give it
back to you um we kind of slide it over
the whole Miami Street PC exclusive to
Windows 10 nobody didn't wanna talk
about
why is everybody doing that that's not
true stop stop something it I've seen
Lauren video they say that you know
Microsoft's exclusives go there but it's
not vice-versa so so what say you rent
what say me
Microsoft Street is the beginning of
Microsoft's for a back into mobile okay
and uh you guys aren't gonna like it
because Microsoft's priority this is
gonna be tough for me to say is an Xbox
anymore Microsoft is looking to look and
it's on it's written on the wall they've
been talking about this many times like
they want to reach 2 billion people oh
yeah blame buy an Xbox oh so they have
the cloud gangster the cloud gaming
streaming division you where do you
reach people when they're on mobile and
PC and stuff like well they're gonna go
there they're they're gonna be making
games for mobile or me making games from
PC and I already know Papa chats I mean
I'm not on web chat up but I can tell
they're probably something recently I
don't know be seeing it but there's a
start for video games online video games
so I do think that a brand you're right
now let me ask you and you think we'll
see Xbox games not specific for the
console but an Xbox game with an Xbox
even score on a phone yes yes
I was watching up I was listening to IGN
and filtered not too long ago and my
McCaffrey and Seamus blackly and
something interesting the same is
was that what they asked him how did you
feel when they launched the 360 he said
honestly my heart sunk a little bit
because the 360 was that it showed
exactly what Microsoft's real reason for
getting into gaming was it was the
beginnings of that and he always said it
he said he said he said OG xbox was a
was a gaming system with with
forward-thinking tech in it but at the
same time it still didn't have what that
360 had which is what the beginnings of
I want to control everything that's
wrong with me ever and I want to be
everywhere exactly he said he it's it's
it's in the company DNA to want to do
that and Xbox pushes against that no
matter the idea of Xbox as a gaming
console pushes against that all the time
he said gamers need to be and kings
gonna love this he said gamers need to
be happy that somebody like Phil is in
charge now because he's a gamer and he's
gonna try to he's gonna try to work that
back into it because if it was just up
to Microsoft and Microsoft philosophy he
said all of the stuff we're just talking
about now raising gaming this this is
what they are Phil's a gamer and this is
true and but he shares the same goals as
Satya he's also Microsoft for life but
what you gotta admit though if Don
Mattrick was still in charge you would
not be dying Don Mattrick would have
been ousted as soon as philosophy wise a
Xbox would still look considerably
different now whoa I would say there's a
there's not given to be made that if if
Don didn't screw up everything about
Xbox Xbox could be essentially winning
this generation because some of the
things that happened right
popping investing in games is a direct
response to what he did and how bad the
Xbox was doing so they're all well I was
just say imagine a situation where they
decide that Connect isn't the future and
they released next box cool and that's
as powerful ps4 for $400 there's no DRM
there's no online check-in coil it may
continue the 360 domination and at that
point consider launch games to the over
commitment to TV whole thing that's it
in a nutshell
exactly that's the whole thing if it was
a 5th yeah no but can you've been
preaching that narrative you you've been
saying it like they had a set up and
then these decisions were like the next
one I'm right into Aaron why you say is
that is that is that while Phil's a
gamer right and he he wants Xbox to
succeed and provide true games for
everybody the thing is he also believes
in sathyas vision because it's also
bills vision of the idea and Phil truly
believes this because I talked to the
guy quite a bit he like wants you to
play your games or whatever and whatever
device you're on if it's on PC great if
it's on Xbox eat great if it's on mobile
whatever they don't want to they don't
want to restrict you from anything there
very unlike Sony in that regard where
Sony's like if you want to play our
games there's literally one option
Microsoft's like just like their core
DNA where they have office 365 and
everything's on iOS and all that stuff
they want to be everywhere so while the
games will come and they'll be you know
great Xbox exclusives also the same time
those exclusives are going to be on your
TV
they'll be on stream to your phone
there's a potential that that [ __ ] will
then be streamed to the switch cuz my
awesome winning oh here we go
wherever they can and they're coming
anywhere and that's just the fact of the
matter you have to make mobile games to
do it that they estimate PC games to do
it they will that's that's what people
just I think people need to realize this
is Microsoft this is Xbox going forward
Xbox is important but it's no longer the
priority and I think people need to find
the real let me explain because there's
a misconception that y'all think that
I'm tied to a box I'm not tied to the
box all right and I want you to
understand one thing
Microsoft is different from those other
two companies that I mentioned
all right Microsoft and like Rand said
you know Sony wants you to prefer they
play their games right here don't you
move from here I want you to play it
right here no matter how bad our
internet is and how much you make
struggle I want you right here all right
Nintendo wants you right there Microsoft
has the Ultron effect the Ultron effect
is anything that has a screen we want to
be on it we want to reach you everywhere
so when you're standing in line wherever
the hell you are they want you to be
able to take out your phone and play
Halo I mean like having that proves that
to like use our system everywhere we
just want misses for the future we've
been seeing the tea leaves is like let's
not you know act like we haven't seen it
continue okay listen
Microsoft doesn't want a screen on and
you're not playing through their system
like Rand said yeah he what they want
you to have achievements pop up on your
phone how crazy is that gonna be if
you're playing pub G through their
servers through cloud base and your
achievement pops up on your phone all
right wherever you had-even are like the
switch I really honestly believe that
thing is gonna really happen I really
believe so because it's ideal for them
it
works for them now that a bus this thing
and a Windows game thing that's all part
of the narrative of being everywhere at
once instead of just being in the living
room closed off so when you feel that
they're changing it from sales to
engagement remember when the music
industry went from sales to streams when
you're Pioneer moving into a different
space there's going to be logical
pushback but Microsoft has always push
forward and drug the other two into the
next millennium this is what's happening
right now
it may grind your gears but it is
necessary for growth and this is not
about monetizing what you have at the
moment this is a role map for the future
this is healthy for the future game past
is healthy for the future because of
Microsoft decides to say today they cut
a check for the companies that they want
to take the Sony promoted games let's
say destiny - what if you go to games
paths and destiny tools in game pass wow
I know probably not but what happens
then when game pass becomes that end-all
be-all and games are being launched
there when I first real third-party game
is launched inside game paths that
triple a third party game whatever it
may be
I don't know but when it's launched in
game past that's the moment change
actually happened my favorite you say
with the four things for being that we
have exhausted this time are we gonna
move right into the next one and it's
it's the subject of our Xbox only
begotten Son
it's our Lord and Savior bill Spencer
and I'm gonna get a go till I set this
one off so pretty much you know a lot of
narrative we hear coming back is that is
this 40 minute topic of game man
is this feels lasting because we're
hearing a lot of narratives you know
that again to make a break mentality we
obviously know about promotion at the
table ahead of Terry Myerson we also
know that you know this is a two hour
show you know there's a lot supposedly
to show last part of the question for
you too is that um you know when are we
as Xbox fans allowed to question his
leadership as that when a when are we
allowed so lord Tim the dog the floors
yours okay all right so the first what
was the first is Yahtzee it was as much
as last and you know to make a break
okay absolutely not and the reason why
is because while the hard core is being
you know ridiculed and then having a
hard go of it guess what Microsoft loves
Phil Spencer okay
Safia loves is you know I think Rand
alluded to it they have the same idea
and fact is is that Microsoft is making
a lot of money even though it's been
shortchanging some of its hard core
so the hard core for the hardcore they
might leave some more people left if you
could even say most left I mean when you
guys a red dragon in jazz every day
smashing smashing xbox the next box you
know that you know it's kind of did lose
that those hard times those you know you
lost those hardcore fans so no he is not
on the hot seat actually if anything
embolden more now that he is an effort
people don't promote a man that many
times if he wasn't doing something right
enterprise what about what about part
two of the question which is when are we
allowed to question his leadership right
now
when it's my turn out you'll go spotless
now I do think that a lot of it might
have been him listen his been things
feel said he's talked about
single-player he was dead wrong on
single-player all right he said well
that's where the industry is going okay
the fact is is that I think film forgot
that he is part of the industry he sets
the industry so he was wrong in that
aspect he was way off on single-player
okay so I think he taken a legitimate
hit there he was right about the Xbox
one X okay we talked about why there was
a dearth who there was a black hole of
gaming now when Xbox one X from what I
heard Meyerson was fully against it
because he said he'd have the Xbox one
ass and he was under the understanding
that you know that that Xbox is powered
enough it doesn't need to need more
power and it's enough there whereas
obviously you know at that time he was
way off but you know the narrative
changed and but he didn't want the extra
hardware so part of getting that
Hardware greenlit and ready to go which
happens supposedly at the start at the
end of 2015 when it was Patty what's the
one like star battlefront was coming out
that that the next January that the next
January if you remember I think the
cancellation started with fable legends
I think Meyerson said hey you got to cut
costs now so gaming gaming creation was
put on the back burner and I think that
they try to push this narrative that you
don't need expensive can I interrupt you
for 10 seconds mm-hmm haven't I said
multiple times that people called me
like crazy that the ex was the reason
that some of these games were getting
cancelled and we weren't seen
development in games have I not said
that multiple times
Laura Cognito no that just doesn't make
sense it's like look Matt like I could
connect the dots I'm look I went to
elementary school
I do what I do I do I do think that that
was that was pushed too hard against him
and I do think the day you know and this
is this is coming from some things that
maybe I know or that the things that
were said to me that I didn't like and I
kept to myself when I do think that they
kind of gave up on single player
development and they kind of gave up on
you know a lot of things like that I
think that they kind of floated like
years and halo being multiplayer-only
okay kind of like will constantly and
that type of that type of talk was going
around so when you say you know when you
say can you think can you judge Phil now
the answer is yes because it's been four
years and he promises like he did talk
about the stable first IPS and he's
sitting on you know he said look at all
these IPS that we have and I remember
him saying in 2014 that they're
dedicated to gaming and pushing gaming
where that you know it kind of wasn't
true for two years and I think that
those two years kind of hurt him in the
eyes of the hardcore and a lot of the
narrative against him is because of that
now do I think that he should be fired
absolutely not I do think some people
feel that way from I know I'm feeling
like they they're saying that he's not
doing a good job that they don't like
the direction that this thing is going
in this is not right so how do you walk
with I think yeah I've seen that
I believe me I read everything I read
all comments the negative comments and
and and you know a lot of a lot of
native comments I read off from guys
that were big Xbox guys destroyers Jen
when you see them constantly upset you
know what I mean so yeah I do think that
he could be judged right now it's been
four years if you've been honest but I
do think that you got to give him a
little a little more time as far as to
see you know what the c3 the c3 is
critical for him and his job evaluation
as far for me I would give him
I'd give him I'd give him around a C at
this point because I feel like the game
creation part was a big mess and some of
the things that he pushed against like
exclusive content you know I think that
sometimes they played this Mary gamer
atmosphere thing in the competitive
world
oh so you feel this side for aggression
they don't have the eye of the tiger and
I think that hurts them and I continues
to hurt them and I don't think that they
address it I think like don't say wow
and like you look at them like like last
year kind of was like a [ __ ] job and I I
probably you know let like but then when
you you talk to like those guys are
actually an argument with some of the
guys that's not what we bought me - I
had the same we walked out this year I
had this Seattle shout our own a Tony's
you're saying but I I some some really
you know close friends of mine youtubers
and stuff and I had the same yeah
actually just I didn't feel it was a
terrible show it just was it for me like
I didn't feel that was like a phenomenal
show and you know I didn't have that
feeling that I was coming into it so
it's funny that you said the same thing
you wanna mean and you had that you seem
to had those same type of discussions
he's in a spot that where he has to
produce he can't you can't be in a
position where you're you know you keep
getting excuses made and I probably have
made excuses for him I think that at
that point you know I think that there's
been a time but I just feel like now is
the time it's like I like Phil as a
friend and all and and do it but the end
of the day
so improve it's all ages right now
because these days Phil is so nice it is
about what you could do for the fans and
that's where I care about the most I
care about the hardcore I care about
that and if you turn a blind eye to them
its I'm not gonna make excuses for that
I'm not gonna defend them on Twitter
like I you know I mean I'm just gonna
call it the way it is at this point it's
it's it's it's you know [ __ ] or get off
the ball we you know we got it we got to
get some kind of you gotta get some
tangible [ __ ] we got to get some stuff
where we can say hey I'm happy to be
there right now there's nothing where
people could say they can't prop up [ __ ]
dude
so saying that chesses is not out let me
get a little rain on this cuz I'm very
curious about him as far as the whole
you know is this his last thing you know
is you know to make a break mentality as
well as the part to to the question when
are we allowed to question Phil's
leadership alright uh well you're
allowed to question his leadership
whenever right now years I mean these
it's like Tim this isn't this isn't your
one this is your four oh look I'm not
really the I'm not I'm biased towards
Ville all right let's go baby oh but the
thing is it feels done a lot for me
personally I have mad respect for Phil I
have mad respect for Mike Ibarra they've
done that see but they didn't have to do
because I have friends so it's it's I
may be not be seeing the picture with
the like clarity because my my well you
know what I mean but you see you got in
trouble for being so and this is the
spot I don't want you in exactly and
don't hold his feet to the fire too hard
on this part
is a friend that is a friend and it was
a friends out there without being his
Clair's you said this I've said this to
Phil personally so I'm just going to
repeat it I said I told him that I felt
I love the hardware I thought they did a
great job taking what was a piece of
piece of garbage and turning it into a
diamond right
I felt that I told him I loved the
services of the system I love like the
the focus on digital digital gifting the
digital self-service refunds all that
stuff on that side the services game
pass phenomenal but I said when it comes
to game creation your studios are
horrible I said I told them I was like
that's the one area I need you to
improve and I said it's a shame
considering that you are first viewers I
had a first party for so long that I'm
not seeing I'm not like it's not that I
don't like the direction that their
games are going in like I like the whole
like games as a service stuff it's just
that you know he said like oh we need
single-player and I want to do
single-player and all this stuff but I
don't see that I don't see the
single-player like I see right actions
and it's like for years like yo you know
like your your stamp should be on there
there should be games that you greenlit
that should be coming out and that's my
that's my biggest issue with Xbox at
this point in time I feel everything
else besides the games is about as good
as you can get and as the games that are
dragging the system's down in my
perspective and perspective other people
they just are okay they're not great
they're not amazing they're not
phenomenal they're not masterpieces
they're just okay and that's not
acceptable from a first party from a
console manufacturer those games need to
be a pluses A's beep
classes at the worst what we're getting
now is just cease Oh people you know you
know and like I want a retake
I want halo to be back how it used to be
where it was the biggest game in the
world I want yeah I want it like I'm
like just a real toy take that back
horizon 3 is a vast apiece masterpiece
but the same day they don't own
playground games this problem with
Microsoft is Jenin extends to last year
the body reliance on second party to
make everything for them if you like
takes off first party and you actually
break it down what have they actually
made this gen I'll tell you
Forza Motorsport 5 Forza Motorsport 6
400 Motorsports 7 minecraft you can't
even include it because it was a game
from last gen Halo 5 can you really
include Master Chief collection because
343 really didn't do anything on it
right gears 4 because somebody else made
that game when you actually list their
first party studios and list the games
they've done it's not it's it's just not
good its Forza halo and Microsoft shot
the kids Smoove halo big neck large
fries and a shake all the time the the
other IPS they built they're all second
party rise sunset overdrive Ori all this
stuff and they it seems like they're
continuing on with that you have you you
give scalebound the platinum and
whatever happens to it and you got to
cancel the game the problem the problem
there is like if you had a first party
studio making that game it's a different
story it's why Sony doesn't necessarily
have these problems because they have
like 10 studios all making different
stuff and they all own them that's my
biggest problem with with Xbox and
extends to last generation when instead
of creating a new IP and bringing that
new IP to next gen they decided to start
around with Kinect
cancel the core games and give us trash
like Star Wars can I be garbage like
that oh then they wonder why they're in
this predicament now they're wonder why
they need game pass
because before the model was halo comes
out and halo is so successful and I know
Tim you know this because we were all
told this halo so successful that it
basically funded five other games Wow
and a couple of those games might be
successful in a couple of them weren't
and that was okay
but it doesn't work in this generation
anymore because Microsoft doesn't have
the users or the user base to support
that idea that much anymore whereas on
the flip side Sony's can Sony doesn't
have game pass because it doesn't need
game pass because moons are people hide
their first party games and they're
successful that way Microsoft has the
opposite issue nobody buys their first
party games and it's and they can't get
gears gears in Halo out because 343 is
in a bad state I've heard halo 6 is
still two years away at this point
oh you're looking at 2020 so Microsoft
needed a different revenue stream to go
after and game Pass provides that the
most important thing is the games and
for someone that wasn't your first party
I the games have been lacking this is
first one shot away for brutal honesty
you know I you know say what a reason
why you're definitely my top five
content creators I mean you always bring
it and these are valid points you know
I'm saying like I'm not trying again
this is not I don't wanna make this like
this is their kill fill segment you know
saying we all know I love you all love
Phyllis I laugh for people that say they
want Don Mattrick back the question was
just at some points like the way I look
at it is I think Tim kind of nailed it
it's like sometimes you can have someone
who is just a great person and I'm not
saying he's not fit for the job not
going there all I'm saying it's just
that you know at some point we have to
judge a person on the merits of their
actions right someone can talk you to
death about what they're gonna do and
what's gonna happen
but you have to look at the resume so
that's where the question came okay when
do we get a chance to say and I see what
Tim is saying that's the I ran it so I'm
gonna give it to grow a king who has
been knows me forever thanks what
sovereign knows me for forever if if I
smell BS don't you know I smell beer you
know right they go but we meet you but
we went to what was his name from 3do
rented out a hole for us right and fed
us they prompt us up it was nothing that
close to fan fest that was sitting down
with devs meeting CEOs eating being
smooth we was being wined and dined it
was fantastic and I saw through all of
that crap all right um and it was nice
crap but it was crap still nonetheless
all right
the beginning of this this this whole
era when the dawn was out and
everything's i I said that I actually
watched it all crumble and I was
probably brought to tears alone by
myself all right awesome brutal
indifference it was horrible it was
horrible with your Xbox fan when Sony
could put out a video and say this is
how we like borrow again yeah I said
because you know what those tactics are
my tactics something that I would do
alright and once it they got public
opinion did you see the turn no
aggressive he got now okay
when we all see filled
we don't see fill when if you playing
gauntlet Phil would be the elf all right
no not the wizard there would be the elf
he strategic and he's using limited ammo
to achieve his goal will not be the axe
he would not be the Berserker he would
not be that brutish guy that we all want
I know y'all wanna knock out some to
come out of the park and don't want to
see what being beaten this this and I
understand this you asked me when do you
start evaluating Phil I studied
evaluating Phil day one day one he
walked in that door because remember at
that same time I had to watch every
video on how the xbox was underpowered I
had to watch every video on how this was
wrong and how this guys were doing this
right had to watch every video on
everything how you were overpriced and
this was underpriced but more power you
know the narrative was so stacked up
against the individual I aligned Phil
with flying in and punk G and finding a
shotgun and there's people inside
pachinko and he's actually working for
[ __ ] with a shot so basically saying
because of in his yet limited ammo
limited resource here the worst what
narrative going against him from the
beginning having to turn this whole
thing around based on the debacle that
was what 2013 everything it was horrible
you know I don't know many people that
would have got that control of that
situation and done what he's done in
that period of time now y'all may say oh
you're blinded with this no he has a
scar now now he's on death okay he has
thus far with an 8 x scope and a full
clip heat that gun is ready here's 500
shots and he's ready to go now he has to
come with these games like like Lauren
said he was the head of the gaming
division that's history he made a full
par when he said that single-player
games are dead you know what's funny
those those same words was crammed down
his throat when God of War came out and
it did what it
those same words was crammed down his
throat when Zelda came out and it did
what it did
Thanks so a lot of times just say why
isn't he talking why isn't he saying
this because he made that football and a
strategic individual won't make the same
attacks mistake twice all right so he
took away the narrative and he's been
doing all this other stuff to compensate
for the lack of ammo going into this
place like Lord Tim dog said and Lord a
ran said halo funded other projects they
don't have that luxury anymore so he had
to find money and another place we find
money and streaming and games from game
paths
okay you find money inside putting games
in the Windows Store okay we're getting
this he changed a narrative from sales
to streaming views and and mindSHIFT
back a write engagement now is the key
word and everybody is saying like it's
as nasty word engaged alright cuz he
does not have sales
okay so engagement is what he's gonna
hold on to and you always hold on to
what's your strongest at he's on deck I
wouldn't give him an A+ like y'all
probably thought I would give him no but
I have faith in that that he can achieve
my highest weight what do you wanna be -
and he doesn't get a b-plus okay so be a
strain to me but giving me that that
wonderful system that I have that X that
actually produces the best multi Platts
on their system and their first parties
look really good um as far as the games
go
where are they fill em
is going to be solely based on these
games Phil like Jess says I am Jess -
he's in me - hmm where are the damn game
mmm let's go let's get to each well at
the point I want to finish with you King
is that when do we say okay you know
we're not satisfied wouldn't wait when
do you get to that point cuz you're his
biggest [ __ ] okay so did this [ __ ] he's
kind of make a break for you this this
fan fest I'm personally want to really
seek him out this fan fest if I get a
chance to speak on um and I'm hopeful
see what everybody doesn't see when I
saw the last year games I saw those
games from the PC show games it was some
games that were our very interested in
um that was shown on a Microsoft stage
but with in-depth and the PC gaming show
and what I want is those games that I
saw because there's a lot of those games
I ran I'm not looking for halo to be
shown today I'm gonna looking for their
gears to be shown today I'm looking for
those IPS those games games you know
something that's gonna get me get those
juices flowing to play these games I
don't need a halo to say the validation
for the system because I know it's
coming and when it's cooked it's cooked
but I want games to keep me from point A
to point B so that's where my thing is
attic man well yet man
what would fill the rating and when do
you reach that point uh I think I want
to say this year okay but I feel like
realistically we're not gonna see [ __ ]
till next year
oh I got you I got you okay no that's
fair that's that's that's you're saying
way to e3
regardless if you make fun of that
statement like what else am I gonna do
like I got a ps4 I got a switch like I
mean you're in my position yeah III I
it's not like I could go like yo feel
gotta talk to you over here for a minute
I've tried I've spoken to people as a
gosh oh it it doesn't matter like if you
need to tease fable for 30 seconds you
need to exactly look at the end of the
day I think it would be beneficial for
them as a conference to show cyberpunk
why well they are showing what you get
what I'm saying
obviously bran say fable if fable was
was good right now and they could show I
do think even though if able to come out
this year it still be more beneficial
from the new show cyberpunk because it's
the most hype game that's out right now
but that's not then they open with fable
oh yeah you know what they could do you
don't Microsoft could do take a page
from Nintendo's book throw up a JPEG of
it's all I would be okay with like a
30-second cutscene or something like
something related see I've been thinking
about what e3 is gonna be and I think I
think it's gonna be just like last
year's I think it's going to be over
over reliance on third-party which is
fine third-party games are cool I love
them Shadow the Tomb Raider we're
looking forward to they're gonna have
the indie stuff probably even maybe some
new cuphead game maybe a cup head like
you know I would be okay with lip
addition cup had to or whatever
something like that and I just I just
don't expect a lot of first party stuff
from them I expect aurilla aspect Forza
horizon for expect something from Gears
maybe something from halo I'm just not
sure they they have like a lot of stuff
to show yet everything that I'm excited
about is two to three years away at this
point and just like Sony Sony's like
we're focusing on right now
we're focusing on these games that are
coming out in the next couple years
because quite honestly the games the
newer games are all for the next
generation of systems playstation 5s in
the x2 it's like I've said multiple
times to like we said I think even me
you once said it ran like Microsoft had
a certain amount of time before Sony
started dropping nothing but bombs and
their time is up like and I'm just
curious to see and I would like to see
what you guys have to say like I know
you guys everybody's like oh this make
it or break it but how are people gonna
feel how are people gonna feel when okay
here's what's a what how are people
going to feel one or if crackdown three
no-shows III oh I'm actually I don't
know if I'm the minority of it but I'm
fine I'm waiting for
I'm excited already I'm fired up because
at the end of the day I don't want that
lack of quality to continue I rather
than as much time as they need to make
sure that game succeeds because you know
I was there last year
you know Tim we were there you know King
we were there what I did not like what I
saw so please put that back in the oven
cook it up take your time
prepare it right right if you want
though a battle royale month so a battle
royal mode on it do what you need to do
but don't show what you should I mean I
was not pleased with it ran right what
I'm saying how is the faint like like
I'm a crackdown maybe maybe crackdowns
ready maybe to come out in July but I
have the sinking suspicion that it's not
and I have this I feel like they're just
going to do their e3 conference and not
even mention it I'll just say in
interviews afterwards that it's push and
that they're given a time and while a
lot of people here who played it like
you know King like didn't really I
remember Kings same unions you didn't
really like it right like it was garbage
or whatever
it's not what you expect from the kind
of title was supposed to be right I'm
just wondering what posed to be it was
just more of the first one like all
these years of development and it was
just an oppressed original crackdown
that's what it is though basically just
a better version of the first game in
some respects the scope is bigger but
yeah yeah you're right
yeah absolutely we expected more from
that how do you think okay we know how
we feel but how do you think the
community will feel if that's the case
the immediate reaction is gonna be
outrage you know that the immediate
reaction what do you think are you still
on for crackdown this year do you think
it's next year I think it'd be great so
the kind of battle royale modes I want
to see right now something you need they
cannot not they cannot do this this game
any more questions you go to you that
show us something about the clarity
cannot go on with this anymore here's
the watch and this is somebody who's a
huge proponent of the cloud you know at
this point you know you you know you
making people it was never a reality
right now here's the question do they
not bring it up at all or do they show
gameplay for the multiplayer say it's
too late oh that's that's tough I'm it's
tough because if you go out there you
show game plan you're like it's not
coming this year at least the same the
same out rate they're gonna be there but
I don't like oh I think it's 10 times
worse if they don't show anything at all
and winning scenarios if they don't show
anything at all I feel like people are
gonna automatically assume it's cancer
let's be real with this game with this
game until it's in people's hands the
narratives gonna be negative period I
don't care how if it comes out this year
and to listen people's hands it's gonna
be negative so I think they just need to
write it out like a look at Last
Guardian Last Guardian came out and it
was fine it wasn't like this wherever
this revelant this revolutionary thing
but you know ten years out it came out I
think the key for this game is for it to
come out and to be in a better in a
better state than it was when we saw it
now and I think that's it for you guys
do you think that if it came out and the
multiplayer did exactly what they
promised it was exactly what they you
think that yeah is the image of the game
I think it helps us yes that's what I
was sold on see do you think what
happened with that game is that was sold
on the cloud and multiplayer aspect is
in this show the single player tacked on
[ __ ] play it
I think they didn't do anything to
expand on the apat the mechanics of the
first game like it's there's nothing
different nothing different so it was it
was that multiplayer to have people
excited well yeah I did it definitely
didn't but you can you remember that
whole thing you know you you're as good
as dead going in you yeah you got some
additional they're not you know a huge
triple-a they don't just make a game as
you know kind of bare minimum but I
don't have asked I don't think this
single players gonna tell anybody I'm
fine with that game but I do think that
if they are the line they're in a battle
royal mode with that it's it's a it's a
it's a needs to be done um but they
definitely have to shoulder the [ __ ]
they have to talk about it and if they
don't they have to get bashed because
it's we've been quiet you know Phil
answer all the questions but then you
ask them about crackdown and nobody
literally answered like 40 questions at
the celebrated crackdown go look I
didn't see that really really quick my
thing is again I just think what it feel
going anywhere no I think he's the
perfect guy for the job I think like you
said Satya and he are on the same
wavelength in terms of where it's going
and I think the fact that bill is a real
gamer and he he respects the hardcore
gamer then in the long term we're gonna
see more of the stuff that we want um in
terms of like is it time to start
judging I think this is the perfect fair
time to do it I think you know despite
what we've heard yeah I think I think he
needs this is a time to show to in good
faith show us what you have its III
people the eyes of gaming the entire
gaming world is watching III why not go
out there and again like we said they
don't have that killer instinct they
don't have that i/o tie they don't have
that Peter Morris that you know people
listen and listen Peter Moore is a
marketing guy right a marketing guy is
is just as liable to look you in the
face and lie to you as anybody else so
big or is it he's good at that right but
the thing about it is my thing is okay
Phil take that right and just I want him
to go out there you don't want to do go
out there with a wheelbarrow full of
mics and just throw one into the crowd
after after every announcement just
throw one into the crowd like one right
after another because I my thing is you
know there's things in the pipeline have
faith and in your development process
and have faith have respect for your
consumers and go out there and give them
what they expect from e3 is about wow I
want to be wowed Wow me you know roll
roll
I want to make I know you roll me thank
you for rocking so long this is really I
hate to leave with my
but you know I have saved me and this is
this is fun man this master I see you
saturday
all right Jeremy
all right so David sir Abby ran the CT
plus now I have to give it a c2 Jesse
he's doing everything right but he's not
doing the thing people but this is me
and Lord kognito yes it's tough a great
he's a Sikh we just see right now if he
if he can change perception you know
Manik you really do something formed
because to me this is his III this one
you know I mean but he's got the box and
now to show those games man just show to
an embrace yeah yeah I don't know I
don't care just break protocol just show
something that maybe a year way you can
throw a splash screen you can throw a
JPEG you can show a cinema something
what you call a the Master Chief and a
poncho show something that okay y'all
working on this you know because Sony
that is something they do well they date
they know how to galvanize their base
with those kind of cinematic
presentations and there's a hope for the
future that's all i yes look at 2016
look at how they they nailed it and and
then even if it's all look at how it
worked out
nobody's complaining that they're gonna
do a deep dive on easily ready now so
you got the template there just do the
same thing you know but thanks guys for
having me I will cycle you Saturdays for
the guys and what a show all right I
have a good one all right so we move on
the last summer's joints and this is the
to drop the mic man so Lord reyne being
that you know everything that's
happening I just want to point out Aaron
how how about that a prediction last
year which prediction for the for the
Microsoft for with well you'd have to
have to refresh my memory on that which
one no your prediction for e3 for
Microsoft last year that video you they
and what was i but III don't remember it
was I right or was I wrong I think if
you were right you would remember oh my
god right I said anthem with close the
show what are you talking about one
perspective look we don't have time to
go you want me to literally go listen to
my let's get into it better drop the mic
segment Lord rain what would be that
drop the mic kill it moment for you
personally that Marcus or could do to
win III well okay I'll keep this I'll
keep this game related because my you
know Phil could come out there and black
by the way Xbox Live called doesn't
exist multiplayers free drop the mall
which so that probably won't happen but
for me personally gets up on stage and
black I've heard your cries urja tears
we're partnering up with respect to
developer for sequel that everybody's
asked for okay an on screen no dims
let's go and uh a little shot of this
just a lap dated house a little of like
a link and you hear Alan wakes voice say
it's
let's go okay they haven't taken Justin
thing we'll give you a couple seconds
hopefully if not then we get you back
but it looks like dealers in the
building you know saying that's what's
up but let's get that on to the Lord
Lord addict what do you need man drop to
my are you fable day now it's like a
halo six I'd be cool but you know
according to ran ain't nothing getting
announced I'm gonna go up there see
Indus for two hours nothing was getting
announced I said you're gonna get ory
you're gonna get fours are rising for
you get a CJ a teaser for six you're
gonna get a trailer for Gears five and
the gears spin-off for a performer and
oh man I expect order to do you expect
what I expect a worgen order part two
the order
these games being announced on from come
on come on I need you I said this before
on another show for me it would be you
bring scalebound back as a Panzer
Dragoon game why are you hating on my
predictions the deal is that you now get
that back oh yeah yeah
so get king man what you got for a drop
to mike moment well what could they do
my Amato walks out on stage okay the
announced they are working with Nintendo
on their online services yeah you wanna
talk about a drug though that's a and
that was literally sent reverberations
through the community that is unheard of
Shane is Nintendo's winning III got you
whoa you know what I'm gonna tell you
this with Microsoft backing there's
that's great because for me III is
they're gonna do exactly what they're
gonna do like ran knows they're gonna do
exactly what they're gonna do
right I know they're gonna do exactly
what they're gonna do my thing is show
that you're willing to reach across the
bus because it was reaching with
minecraft minecraft' is over there don't
think it's not you know they've been
playing nice with these guys just make
that deal I want them to close a deal
man close the deal already closed a damn
dick
yeah I mean this is yeah I think like
drop wow I think it's just simple for me
never just trying to talk Oh deal I'm
sorry now there we go from adjust that
way I clearly AM I clearly audible now
you know new mic it's done over used it
before so that's cool I'm trying to
figure it out so sorry once again power
got stuck on the roof you know the whole
nine yards we still go get that intro
Lord who in my opinion is content
creators in a game despite his stature
in the community this Lord is extremely
approachable and his daily content
always exemplifies unique perspective
and technical savvy all done with that
trademark you introducing the creator
and host of the RDX podcast in these
xbox treats an exposure of frauds with
misinformation the Reaper of gaming
fresh out the trunk making his return to
the realm of the Lord
mom made Lord ELA game and what's going
on baby uh not much man just uh I was
looking for the show and then all this
crap happened so unlike myself and say
sorry I was a mercenary insulted you ran
out of gummi bears
only person I know that will make like a
like a 15 20 minute video and then kid
will be like so how you think the vide
is gonna use like do it I could I made a
cool ass skin at the beginning okay yeah
I did it just for that skin it was a it
was the gremlin one that that's what it
was that your talk is like whatever
[Laughter]
we're at the section so as far we just
want to talk about the drop the mic
moment what could Microsoft actually
woody rates Phil no no up until this
point and when do you kind of what's the
point where you kind of question when do
you think we allowed to question his
decision-making so the first part is
well you rate them and when you think
it's you know sorry
well I think you're allowed to question
Phil from you know minute one since you
could see they're right because you know
why not right on the pro-consumer side
of things how Pro consumers feel the
policy changes I'd say I give Phil a
nine out of ten he got rid of the xbox
live pay wall to watch YouTube and
Netflix yeah
about also implemented play anywhere
which like it or not does give you an
extra copy of a game at no additional
charge play with your friends wherever
you want
I didn't hear people complaining about
that with the ps3 and Vita cross-play
stuff so I think it's extremely
pro-consumer and he's only tried to do
more in that vein getting past you can't
beat it really I mean people like to
talk down about it but it's really it's
for you or it's not either on those
games on day one or maybe now you want
to say some money with the
implementation of first party in the
game pass but extremely pro-consumer in
my mind but on the game side have to
give Phil a [ __ ] you know the
alphabet as far as we will be rating up
yeah all right okay
so yeah so
I don't want to bother your role he was
on a roll give them a like a scene in
problem right yeah
so you're in the C range right now but
even mine were like less you know like
I'm a little over a week from e3 so that
could change but I don't feel like it
will this year okay and now let's speed
this up to where we are now which is the
whole III in that light
drop the mic mode what can they do for
you Lord they let could just oh like
that will kill the show for you well
like many of you I do not pretend like
third-party games don't exist so a lot
of stuff I said it forever going xbox
nation expect like a lull for like a
year and a half two years up the ex
comes out well you're not gonna be
getting too many games like it's just
how things are gonna be they're gonna
rely on third party to fill in that gap
and I'm excited for a lot of stuff
they're probably gonna show like shadows
the Tomb Raider in cyberpunk and an
anthem and Metro comes out early next
year you know but first party wise I
just don't see him doing too much this
year honestly I mean it really
after talking Iran I'm like crackdowns
[ __ ] 29 is looking at all the grades
and answers right there so it's it's a
little disappointing but it sucks that
it is what I thought it would be just a
lull for a year and a half two years
seriously nope no damage control because
we all like got a war right got all over
Salerno we want games like that first
parties like that that have a lot of
polish five years of development and a
big budget but at the same time we're
all having a great time playing third
parties too so I'm still looking forward
to seeing those third party games I
think they're both very important you
know what sucks
is that correct does come out this year
everybody's just gonna dealers gonna
come at me and be like your fraud
collaboration video because if
everything I predicted turns out to be
right I'm an [ __ ] but if I be wrong
I'm frauds
I think definitely like especially after
a greenberg [ __ ] he deviant so hard
his mics caught on fire said that it
wasn't delayed you know like he knows
the [ __ ] stole age I mean you know that
because they said spring spring ends on
June 20th no that's lame if it ain't out
in 17 days yeah it's not it looks like
it's not going to meet that or anyone
else would who hasn't made their drops
to Mike moment let's get that lets get
that problem hold on I want to dealer
like I said mine Mike even though this
won't happen and I know it won't happen
the drop of Mike moment for me would be
Microsoft announcing Alan Wake - so
you're saying like there's nothing that
would be the draw - Mike moment for your
and they even have you can hand out like
a packet of Twinkies - everyone lawdy
insan' that would be a bigger moment for
me honestly is interesting a personal
thing Alan Wake to me is very I'm
wondering
want to get to know more about dealer
gaming yes let's get to the dealer
what would Microsoft announced as its
about the games yes it's the third party
stuff on the outside cuz third party
stops great but specifically a game of
question right good question challenge
to me drop the mic don't give me that
third party crap let's get real now well
I mean it depends if they announced
fable Andy and it's intricate which I
know it's not gonna be that's the thing
that's why I so hard if it were as
intricate and just next-level like
witcher 3
but maybe retains some of that charm
that would be like holy [ __ ]
Able's back you know if they announced
this one it all depends on how much time
they put in these games and i we all
know they haven't had enough time so
make a salt same thing make it so clean
so drop the mike moment it's never
happened to if they announced a xbox
live free now that which wouldn't happen
a big thing that would that's very pro
consumer for me yeah but you know we're
talking about fantasy worlds here that's
three things that had to run by right
now put some stuff out there in the
universe
those have anybody else didn't get there
right drop the mic in who didn't get
they jump in like it so yeah yeah you
have nobody's good yeah I think for me
yeah it for me just like I think dealers
on it I mean I doubt it happen but if
they have some type of announcement of
like a game pass you know Xbox Live kind
of combo deal you know I'm saying that
would be really cool you know kind of
embracing game press in that form you
know also I think I need I need to see
Splinter Cell I need to see Splinter I
mean we've already had the inside Xbox
we've seen michael ironside on that you
know platform it seems like it's a goal
you know Ubisoft has been kinda you know
so I mean who knows if they'll get it
exclusive but you know that would be
kind of cool you know ultimately you
know like what King was saying a dream
you know saying would be summer you know
you know they're working with the
discord thing and you know somehow they
want to get services on everything how
about getting in tendo's up to snuff
exactly it's not it's not drop the mic
is something that's gonna send shock
wait I'm in a drug you know when you
drop the mic in the sound that you make
that's what they want you to have that's
a drop the mic so drop the mic is not no
ordinary something like a game like oh
that game came out thanks no a drop the
mic is changing stuff so to me for them
to change it it would be there my own
motto walking out on stage and I will
really be like that you will see us a
change something will really happen
alright let's get to the fun part Lord
dealer what announcement would you hope
is not made let's go dealer let's hear
this I don't want anything you guys can
hear me right I don't want anything to
do with Minecraft there I know you fraud
they spend another ten minutes of
Minecraft I'm gonna punch a hole through
my old lady I don't want anything to do
with I mainly minecraft you see if these
me like big things right but I mean
statistically I guess but there's
there's a there's a place for those
things and it's it's like a news
briefing or some kind of piece on the
online or something you know so give me
some new
big-ass [ __ ] games and that's really
all I want really I mean third or first
I like to know what they're doing in the
future but like it says it's gonna be
kind of like last year but the games are
just further along this time really
that's how I feel about you three it's
gonna be kind of like last year but you
just got an anthem that's a year further
in the development things like that so
crap no CDs double dealer stays a family
Jamie Moran shout-out to him on Twitter
he said he doesn't want constant cuts to
the crowd during gameplay I agree with
dealer on the no see thieves no
minecraft nobody wants to hear that
stuff yeah I also don't want to hear or
see anything about VR and I also don't
want to hear or see anything about
streaming get Xbox games to mobile oh
you don't want to see I don't want to
hear about I want to see it I don't want
them to get up on stage your galaxy I
don't want to see any of that stuff fair
enough fair what so what would disgust
you what don't you want to see oh that's
me I was gonna say fable but that's bad
I don't want to see a car on stage again
yeah I don't want any awkward fake
interaction gameplay demos with people I
call like like see if TV last year you
for like these guys are like you know
these fake interactions they have and
don't do any of that just somebody
see over there why we're here halo 6 or
a lot yo u Fonz I know and no fake demos
just play the game music artist
no pain no Pele I don't know Bayless
Lord addict this gonna be funny what
don't you wanna see your Microsoft stage
oh well first off I don't wanna see
Nintendo on Microsoft's the purpose let
Nintendo announced that [ __ ] I don't
want to see any cringe-worthy
announcement moments I don't want to see
any callers I don't want to see
minecraft I don't want to see
technically want to see stage of decay I
don't want to see any kind of statistics
on Hardware I don't want to see no
engagement numbers no engage oh just
because I attacked your precious
Nintendo dreams no I don't like I like a
good middle ground you know some
companies like to go from game to game
and there's some companies like that I
have a lot of talking and then go in the
game I want like a minimum amount of
talk and get the point across then go to
the game I don't want like this couch
moment that I think ps4 Xone you talk
about a game for 30 minutes I want just
a good you know good pacing from game to
game two hours long there's not gonna be
good pacing I can almost guarantee two
hours yeah you know it's funny you said
I was jumping real quick King on York
for you jump go game I agree with addict
in this sense like we all know that at
least I feel that the Daryl Galaga
announcement is going to be made but I
don't want to see him
on stage is sitting there talking if he
ain't got nothing to present you don't I
mean like not ask mighty weak we know
that they're investing in the first
party I'm cool with that but like like
what III need the pacing of the show to
be games games games games games and
amount of thing is getting OVR please
PLEASE with the VR you know saying I
can't that get that out of there and
there's no mixer streamers either for
Larry show you know when Larry does is
daily I don't want it like I don't mind
one trailer indie games spotlight but I
don't want to see like three but you
don't you don't my way attic you don't
want that this is which I don't mind one
but like last year I felt like they had
like three of them man like I don't want
no fake verbage we have to confirm ran
is there gonna be I'm not an insider I
don't have these things it'd be a little
bit too much dealer like gonna be Xbox
Windows 10 and Randle Thor exclusives
hey do we even know if the shows two
hours long cuz I'm pretty sure it's not
know they've just blocked off the
schedule for two hours doesn't mean the
cut at the conference is two hours I'm
pretty sure it's not okay video title
did not say that when we do that I'm
making fun of the people in the comment
section who undoubtedly called it
clickbait because you couldn't fit 800
characters yo that's that's what I'm
smart that's what I'm trying to do like
I tried to get you to click on my video
that sort of everything like to watch
the cards that you were putting in the
video oh well fair enough
Lord King well is my mistake what do you
not want to see I don't want to see the
reintroduction of Connect 3 I don't want
to hear we have perfected to technology
control of this power 3 I think economy
it's like now we're gonna demonstrate a
game and RAM comes out there
demonstrates a game tied to fight night
let's kill this big man we went crazy
low in the day dealer I'm just gonna
give you an exclusive just straight for
because he missed a lot but future of
Microsoft was the last topic we gotta
get out of here um just strict with you
like what how do you feel they handle
you know the transition and possible
release date in reference to the next
platform well for sure they got a for
sure they got a BES cheaper cheaper now
at the same time or sooner and they've
got to have the same or better hardware
and and even if they buy the same chip
right yeah they could still invest money
in superior cooling design to up clock
the chip right there's all kinds of
stuff they could do so they've gotta
have all of those things I believe and I
don't know if you watch mine ps5 2021
clip because a lot of people like even
red dragon came out said Sony did not
say 2021 right according to The Wall
Street Journal he did say 2021 but in a
roundabout way says we'll spend the next
three years working on the fifth
generation PlayStation that's 2021 now
I'm not saying you know lockdown for
sure but you never know they could be
tricking they could but it that's an
investor's meeting they can't lie their
investors like that so the whole point
of that meeting was to say hey we're
crouching down for three years don't
don't sell your stock you'll regret it
alright we're standing up in three years
and I'm definitely not standing up when
I'm launching another PlayStation
I'm already I'm already standing up
during that launch I'm not crouching
during that launch so that launched me
says 2021 and according to Wall Street
Journal they they say that he said that
so I will say that Microsoft had that
much time to figure out what's going on
they actually got it really good this
time Dec if this is true they know when
it's coming they have enough time to
figure out what's going on that's enough
time to get their games going so they
have to have compelling software the
price has got to be better just the same
hardware the same thing but now they got
to convince all these people that have
invested so much in digital goods
well like you got people that bought
thousands of dollars worth of ps4
digital games right for the first time
ever it's like me leaving behind like
you imagine
how much Sony would have to do to
convince me to leave behind my 500 games
back weapon them not having back with
them not even trying to have that really
would be an issue
this time right and the ps4 games will
be playable and that's what I tell these
PlayStation guys say you better not be
excited about playing your ps4 games in
your PS 5 though because this whole time
you didn't care about the old games in
the backpack stuff so you definitely
want to end up that way but at the end
of the day Microsoft would have to do
all that but but that's where it gets
complicated because unlike the previous
generations you know you got all this
digital stuff that's gonna come with you
forever think of it like Steam it's not
going anywhere ps4 games will be
playable on the PS 6 and you've got to
convince those guys to leave thousands
of dollars or with the games behind and
come over to the other platforms so that
means you got to do a lot I mean I don't
even know what all they could do to
convince the hardcore I don't think they
ever will be ever convince the crazy
hardcore PlayStation guys to leave and
come over to Xbox but for the casual
you've got to be the price is the
biggest thing for the casual so they've
just got to nail that I don't think
they're gonna be behind the power again
either someone it'll be interesting to
see what they do but 20 21 is plenty of
time to figure out that hardware thanks
to AMD roadmaps that are already out I
mean you're gonna have you know they
already know what they're doing and when
it comes to the timeframe that should be
enough time for them to get those new
games outright ran you think that's
that's true that's more than enough time
2021 that's what I've been saying all
this stuff is all in preparation for the
next Hardware cycle which is in two to
three years which is why I don't expect
them to show anything this year this is
too far away and it's for the next next
generation of consoles from but
historically at least on Sony's side
they showed stuff right at the end of
the generation know it and last of us
was came out in 2013 you know that was a
year offer the same right but I mean
like Sony wasn't showing ps4 games until
that year when they announced the ps4
yeah that's true
that's which which is exactly what the
play they do in all production on IPs
that's a ps4 well right and that's the
difference Microsoft
didn't do like they went with connecting
connections instead of making new
varieties and franchises at the end alas
yet and that makes it harder to predict
everything because yeah Microsoft
weren't a flux that whole back half
there Don match is like no they want
board games and everyone else like no
they want regular games and and no one
knew what was going on there's a big
transition and Phil gets transitioned up
again then Matt booties and it's been a
whole you know but the quite a question
dealer I have for you ran is that do you
think they can afford for Sony to drop
first Microsoft has to be first or a
bare minimum the same year exact
considerably more powerful maybe they
can get away with it me gotcha
they cannot launch later and more
expensive even if they are more powerful
we've seen how that story and while the
XS were pro in sales like comparatively
the two iterative upgrades the Xbox guys
and I've always said this to have had
more of a reason to buy the new
iterative upgrade than the ps4 guys have
because you've generally had pretty
stable resolutions on the PlayStation
whereas if you're coming from an X 1s I
mean this is a pretty big massive jump
absolutely police station pro and a
stock PlayStation 4 because they just
haven't put in the RAM to give you the
better textures and stuff like the X can
do so absolutely absolutely I tell
everybody all the time make sure that
you get an X if you can afford an X
because if you're playing on xbox that's
really probably the only way to play
right now they got him for the future
you know wrap this thing up man with a
shout out the Tim dog coming through in
the brown the running gag is you and Tim
dog on the same exact
left and right later you popped up okay
so and then you have an issues with your
mic so they said that you were getting
your voice the same place at the same
time you know came through man
tremendous love and of course about the
Lord rained in the building
Xbox mafioso style the dawn himself
where can define people find you what do
you have cooking of it uh you know
people can find me on the YouTube
channel youtube.com slash Randall for
nineteen as for what I got coming up I
don't know I really haven't any videos
planned I'll just play that stuff by ear
but I'm sure will be mean jazz since
jazz isn't going to e3 this year and
neither am i back to of that code day
we'll be doing probably your reaction
show to xbox after the conference is
over and who knows what else I'm greatly
looking forward to the next week
it's like Christmas for me I'm sure I'll
be pumping out a lot of videos so check
me out there know that absolute pleasure
man and love what you guys are doing and
of course more deal of the dawn of the
audience mob family what do you can find
me on you can definitely find me at
dealer gaming here on YouTube
dearly gaming on Twitter we're we're
just doing a Bioshock collection
giveaway with my buddy Cognito they're
fantastic games by the way I don't hear
people talking about this remaster
remake rather because it's it's so good
it takes some of the best games of all
time and makes them even better so we're
doing a giveaway there on Twitter so if
you haven't check that out check that
out and you know once again just sorry
for being late had all good man you got
the man lost power
gotta give appreciative to have you huge
fan of what you guys are doing hardiek
shout out to the crew badge
you guys just makes me laugh he is so
funny about xbox - I love what you guys
do it that's cool says get the ouch was
going on Lord addict man what's going on
with you man we got cooking up any
difficult game to conquer we got
probably gonna stream the other day or
Noah I know someone in the comment
section will correct me about 30 times
but you know feel free to do that you do
the comment section - I am going I do
want to thank you know tiller ran and
beast and dog you know we always be
cracking jokes on each other and it's
it's a it's nice to get everyone in the
same the same dealer is these main
watcher tails let's throw away the blame
ran just say brand knows everything so
this entire prediction video expect all
of that doesn't happen attack ran
personally Adam
you realize people say that be you have
any issues Fordham dealer turned around
at random school wrong predictions at
total predictions people like reason
they're called prediction of they're
wrong they're wrong it's not a big deal
got a massive bet and you bet the dogs
and the kids and [ __ ] on it that's like
that's like my dude kids spooby I think
you've got some bond he's gonna lose
people what we got going on with that
yeah well what do you have going on with
that on Twitter what we're gonna finish
out everybody's thoughts and we'll do so
where can they find you handle games no
not playing no games until you you put
down on that pay to play saw and I got
four just making like a a custom stream
thing for patrons like hey to play games
with this guy no I'm not charging to
play away out come on at least I will
play a better game
so quick big shout-out to Turan - dealer
to be a ridiculous show and a big
shout-out to the chat man you guys were
over a hundred and fifty strong the
whole three hours we've been here so
guys you know come back for the next
hour the best [ __ ] party
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
listen conscious cheer - popular -
belief every Lord can sell your shirt
alright alright so understand that if
you're in contact with any of the Lords
they will
take your order and I handle shipping
hold mister spotlight a whole segment of
t-shirts and going through all that
stuff and how to get it from us so if
you follow us you understand pricing and
everything that's separate from this
because we doing patreon today and I
want that to have its own spotlight
thank you for everyone that has
purchased shirts that has contributed
that helps out ILP that helps out the
community we're gonna be in LA next week
we're gonna be live-streaming everywhere
everywhere that you can find us we'll be
there from the moment that I jump on the
plane I'm gonna be live streaming to the
moment I get off back in New York I'm
gonna be live streaming okay but all the
support thank you all the six colorways
is beautiful only the pink is a woman's
cut so I don't know if a guy wants a
pink for itself
I don't know how is gonna work for you
also at the same time there's a free
rent is a free card giveaway right in
each card that's going to be given out
is gonna have the logo and the name of
each Lord all right but also on that
card will be a coupon okay that's part
of the raffle we're gonna be doing alive
when we get back to New York that first
IOP that Sunday will be live on air
raffle giveaway for three games of your
choice I don't care if you play
playstation switched PC Xbox whatever
you win is your choice is real okay so
find us oh one more thing
one more thing these are the special
shirts occasional so if you catch any
Lord walking around wearing this shirt
you show him that you followed the iron
Lords pocket
find out that Lord will have a card on
him he will give you a card in for the
raffle for the free game so you don't
have to purchase at all to have a chance
of winning a free game all right heavy
dirt comes with a raffle yeah King David
putting some da Vinci Code [ __ ] yeah the
people watching am OCD man like the
podcast I needed a hundred solve pay the
bills man we got it hi guys oh yeah I'm
just gonna give up give up big shout
outs our patreon supporters but we got a
bill like I said before we added three
more tears today to kind of represent
myself and Lord Cognito and and Lord
addict a little bit better we all know
Lord Lord addict loves his TA loves it
loves it so so take a look at that if
anything that was was there before
didn't necessarily catch your eye just
take a look at those new tears and yeah
so just want to give a shout out to
everybody who support us from the jump
we start off with Lord Michael Lugo
thank you so much for your support
brother you you're in there every single
day every single week during the chat we
got Lord bills still well always an
honor to have to have somebody in the
industry just come out and rep like that
so that great honor much appreciate it
then of course Lord irrelevant native
who's in a chat every single week
supporting fraud by IOP shirts thank you
so much Lord native
Lord spoon man and always in the chat
always reppin out and in listening okay
let me go to the Lord cat daddy fat
there we go to Lord snail killer aka
Diego Padre so what's for your for the
support brother we appreciate it
Lord death sing again you're in the chat
every week we appreciate all the love
man and of course last but not least
Lord Peter Lyon
thank you so much for all you've done
repeatedly on we will be getting up with
uh with Lord Cognito to set up the time
when he's gonna be on the show he's
gonna get you're gonna come on and do
his greatness oh and then Lord that
singer of course he is going to be
radically intros
he know he gets to do the whole thing
the whole ship over the whole show and
Lord Iago Pedro he's gonna be doing the
intros he's gonna have intros all to
himself so guys you know get at Lord
kognito
myself any more any one of us in the DMS
to sort of setup all that stuff in terms
of scheduling um and we'll definitely
get that going so let's get into these
uh these giveaways real quick we're
gonna start with the ten dollar giveaway
um since Windows Update folded my whole
microphone situation I'm doing this off
the phone so I can't screw I'm not
screen sharing the the random name
picker but be assured that you guys can
trust me and pay the price off yeah a
place off okay so we're gonna start out
with the ten dollar card giveaway
remember it's a game card a digital game
card for you know whatever platform of
your choosing more than happy to you
know whatever you want okay so we're
gonna start with the 10 dollar game card
and the winner of that card is with a
lord snail killer Diago pedro so get us
in the DMS
yes sir and we will take care of that
okay now the $20 card we have the $20
card and one of the $20 game
is Lord cat daddy cat daddy
[Music]
congratulations congratulations all
right and now let's see now the winner
of our free t-shirt yes Lord spoon man
always complaining in the gym the winner
of the free game the bimonthly free game
giveaway is drumroll please Lord Peter
Lyon yeah so Pete let us know in the DMS
what game you want we're more than happy
to get that out to you it digit a
digital game so yeah again guys thank
you so much for the support like again
we this is this is humbling and baffling
to us all at the same time like I said
we added some more tears so you could
torture us even more at your leisure so
like I said solve you good everything's
good yeah everything's good man thank
you guys absolutely yeah we had to pay
the bills oh sorry yeah but um yeah man
we're gonna be out there III you already
know what it is it's gonna be a big show
we gonna do a lot of live stuff for you
guys obviously audio and all that good
stuff is gonna come up or shout out to
Yvonne says flashpoint is going to be
coming up with a special one on Tuesday
that will be live with the gear - yeah
that's gonna be if you want jumping on
an attic let me know we're gonna do that
when we out you know when we I don't eat
three tickets gonna be in the building
we're gonna be running out there's gonna
be me and Sam Tolbert when we hit the
ground running providing a lot of
contests of stuff I cannot talk about
right now but please stay tuned to the
channel Lord King you already know
what's gonna be down going down and fan
fest he's got a ton of things going on
swag intact
please follow us all over our social
media we had a lot of things trying to
make a huge presence there shout to
everybody in the chat again Lord dealer
Lord Ram Lord tempt off the Xbox mafioso
lock console naw strap it was in effect
baby there's a thing of powers that's
what we had to do today two dollars with
drought ran with one of the best
personal rants ever he was killing it
today thank you so much we really
appreciate you guys you guys are
definitely I'm a huge fan of you guys
and thank you for being on the ILP
everybody enjoy your Sunday if anybody
got anything else to say we can get out
of here man
yeah good all right peace